we have a question when when you travel
to the Philippines did you go anywhere
besides just Manila or color.all Khan or
did you get to kind of see other islands
as well yeah I wish we we did a lot of
traveling throughout like Manila and
kind of the surrounding areas and then
we only took one hopper to the island of
Palawan mmm that was the only time that
and then yeah that was the only like
kind of you know I mean we got you you
know we got that we got to stay at the
one world I think the the world
Philippine hotel which was really really
nice I got to drink Malbec every night
thank God yeah right I brought like six
bottles in my suitcase but if I don't
hit my ball back I'm screwed the first
time you had ever gone to the
Philippines or did you have do you have
experience like traveling to like a like
a third-world country anywhere else in
the world or Southeast Asia honestly you
guys honestly so I used to be on a board
in La Jolla
it's called Friends of Madre Bettany
States and we would raise money to buy
to the paper shipping containers and
then we would get medical companies to
donate you supplies and we ship them we
supported a hospital an orphanage and an
AIDS clinic so we would go down with
like thousands of dollars in our money
belt and hand it out all these kids oh
but I got the I got to shack up with the
nuns
I got to sleep in the nice
air-conditioned area and I couldn't go
out at night they locked us in at night
but um yeah I'm telling ya that was a
fourth world country at the time yeah
good night that doesn't even hold a
candle to where um Rose lives that was
yeah you know those scenes those scenes
with you showering with her dad and seen
the rat rat were so [ __ ] funny dude
and I will say ed you know what he he's
traveled with me to the physical
topology and he's a baby so I want to
give you credit for even what you did
honestly that night I didn't think I was
gonna make it I was crawling around I
don't even know what time it was I found
it a benadryl in my luggage and I didn't
I couldn't even find the water because
there's no electricity went out there
yeah it's raining like it's just like my
head and I had to use my own saliva just
the swallow sick I probably got like an
hour of sleep I woke up literally I'm
soaking wet
I'm sweat and you're like a P o W like
whatever anyway and I'm like and then
then I get up and I'm like okay I just
want to take a shower and I didn't
really know where that where the shower
was yeah and then we walk by the dad's
room
it's he was gonna stay with us actually
that night yeah we walked by his room
and I thought he was kidding I want to
bathe with you what so ya know we're
poured buckets on her heads yeah with a
hose okay
literally like you can't you can't make
this [ __ ] up
you cannot yeah this is what I was
trying to explain to Bobby
so like communal bathing is a very big
it's sort of a very common thing for us
like even today Bobby makes fun of me
because when my family comes over it's
not unheard of that I shower with both
my mom and my sister kind of like a nice
way to meet to bond Mikaela every time I
tried to do that at church camp it
looked at me like I was weird ya know we
all shower together right no but
seriously um when I saw that rat I'm
like holy [ __ ] this I literally here's
the first thing I thought about was cuz
it wasn't even was literally almost dead
and I'm like did I did I sleep on that
thing all night yeah I was I also add
that I we adore you but I also just want
to give a lot of props to to Rose I know
firsthand what it's like to grow up and
certain family members of mine that grew
up in not very